I got this uh... tattoo... couple years ago.
Maybe two years.
It's not the best tattoo.
'Cause... For example, if you roll up- If I roll up my sleeve...
Kinda looks like two balls hanging out.
[laughs]
You may be familiar with it already.
It's uh... It's a figurine made by KAWS.
Which used to sell for like 50 bucks, but I think now they're like two grand.
If you're lucky enough to find one.
'Cause KAWS has gotten so popular.
And I was really worried when I got it, 'cause I thought... Maybe even too popular.
And yeah... In some ways uh...
I was right.
*laughs*
I cringe every time.
Another reason you might recognize it previously is because, uhm...
The figurine is a variation of Astro Boy.
Which is a '50s, '60s Japanese super hero.
And if you search Astro Boy on YouTube, you'll find a picture typically where he's fist towards the sky with a smile.
Uhm...
Striking that super hero pose.
But in this variation, Astro Boy is uh... leaned forward. He's uh, covering his face.
In shame.
And we see Astro Boy in a way that typically would never happen, at least in the original manga.
And uh... And I think when you're a character that people look up to...
It's not typically to show certain types of emotions.
For me, seeing Astro Boy in a way that's so... unlike the typical way that people usually perceive him...
I know it's a little cheesy.
Made me think it's okay to not always be the way you're typically seen by people.
[laughs]
Although we might never actually see it, everyone gets down every once in a while.
Everyone feels the way as good 'ole Astro Boy feels.
No matter who you are.
Although...
We might not actually ever see it.
Everyone gets down from time to time.
Even if you're a super hero... like Astro Boy.
So it's my favorite tattoo.
I'm back, and uh... I feel so much better to be back already.
If you don't know, I took some time off to work on Scare Pewdiepie Season 2.
The sh- My- My own show.
It should be coming out early next year.
It was so much more intense.
Way more than I ever expected.
This season really steps it up so much.
And I really- I feel really confident that you guys, you bros... Anyone really will really enjoy watching it.
'Cause we had such a blast filming it.
And I think each episode on this one is really strong.
I'm probably not supposed to say this, but Jacksepticeye is sort of a villain of the show.
And he flew in the last couple days to shoot some trailer stuff with me.
We got ot do some Kung Fu moves.
We got to ride a motorcycle.
And uh... It's just awesome. It was so much fun.
I worked every single day that week, but it was totally worth it.
And in the finale, we kinda went head to head.
In the end, we were both kinda up on the stage in front of a... everyone that worked on the show, and it was just a really, really awesome moment.
So memorable for me.
Uh...
Don't want to spoil anything, but I was just really happy Jack was there, and it was cool to share that moment with him.
I'm so excited for you guys to watch this season.
I wanna say a huge thanks to everyone who worked on the production.
They obviously worked ten times harder than I did.
And... I just really appreciate all the hard work that went into it.
So everyone that worked on it, you know who you are, thank you.
All the guests that came and went on the show, everyone was so good.
We didn't have a single bad guest.
Some even flew over to L.A. just to be part of the show, which I really, really appreciate.
And uhm...
Just thank you.
Thanks again to Brad and Michael for flying over with me and being part of me while I did this.
They were huge help, and I really appreciate their support.
Same with Marzia, of course, for supporting me these three weeks and being by my side.
She obviously took time off her... what she was doing to be with me, and uh... I really appreciate that.
But also... thanks to you on my last video, all the support was just incredible.
And it means a lot that you were all there for me when I needed it.
And uh... everyone that contacted me and wrote me to make sure I was okay.
I'm really fine.
I really have... [laughs]
I really have the best life ever.
I have no reason to complain or "Oh, boo-hoo I'm stressed."
But uh... I think it's normal to get down every once in while.
I'm just so happy to be back.
I'm excited to make videos again.
And... uh... I'll be back tomorrow with another one.
Edgar... Edgar, come here.
I'm finally back with Edgar.
[kisses Edgar]
[laughs]
[dog's mind] "I missed you, Poods. I missed you."
Edgar's gotten fat now.
The one that took care of him clearly fed him too much.
[laughs]
I don't think Edgar has any objections to that.
So yeah.
Don't mean to keep saying thank you, but thanks for all your support.
Thanks for waiting for me when I'm gone.
I really appreciate that I have an audience that uh... support what I do in a way that... is more than just videos almost.
If that makes sense.
Really kept me going throughout these days, and I appreciate you.
[kisses]
So as always, we're gonna end it with a brofist.
Thanks for leaving a like. I guess I gotta beg for that now that YouTube changed the system.
And I'll see you bros in the next video.
Stay awesome, bros.
I almost... How could I forget?
I haven't met Slippy in three weeks.
I hope he's alive.
Aww...
Slippy...
How you doing, buddy?
I missed you.
Don't shit.
How you doing?
My little cheeseburger.
Oh.
You gonna shit?
Are you pissed that I- Oh, he's gonna shit.
Probably pissed- I'm sor- Hey, Slippy, I'm sorry.
Look at his legs.
Well I've missed you too, Slippy.
Never change.
My man.
It's a sign of affection when they shit.
It means they love you.
Right?
[song]